derrick shelton his good buddy rocco
baldelli they've had a good back and
forth going going back to a last year's
spring training before the game this is
something that i've seen a lot of over
the years i mean i've watched that
infomercial that is uh
the
speed hitter derek shelton pitched when
he was a coach in tampa many years ago
that is actually derek shelton
and one of the commercials or
infomercials as uh
baldelli called it and he during his
press conference his zoom press
conference today
he had it there the whole time talked
about how
inspirational
the commercial was and
how important
that speed hitter
is
michael pineda as we talked about in the
open just
a model of consistency
establishes the fastball finishes with
the slider strike one right i mean that
it really is the fundamental thing for
anybody who hopes to pitch well
first pitch lifted left center field
carol off after it buxton after it and
byron called him off and again
today
twin starting pitcher throws one pitch
and gets it out
high fastball got it now that's 91 miles
per hour but he put it in a good spot
and he put it in that up upper part of
the zone or just above right after
throwing at one on the just off the
lower outside corner and that's what
this is the beauty of michael pineda and
the 2-1 pitch has popped up back of
third
donaldson out measuring with the play in
fair territory two-hand catch for out
number three pineda three up three down
cahill 33 years old working to luis
to start left-handed batter
how did he
hit that ball and he hits it to moran
well looked like he was going to hit the
ground that colin moran
routine
ground ball
that was it yeah hopefully no copyright
or information
okay you gave him credit
and a little roller
two outs on the ground talking about
some veterans 40 years old and another
ground ball and plenty of time for
cahill you don't have to hurry that not
with cruz
one two three
you never get an account where you think
okay i'm ahead i'm gonna get a fastball
that i like on the outside edge
impeccable command
and and he hit the glove got the call
you get the second and third with less
than two outs gives you so many more
opportunities to score
it to the shortstop this will do the
trick
oh and safe at first
and heading toward third is polanco safe
talk about the hustling battling box of
2021 todd frazier knocks the ball out of
osterdio's glove
he was running as hard as he could
the ball jarred loose
gonzalez scoring and
polanco
heads to third it's now first and third
a run in one nothing pirates in the
second inning michael perez looking for
his first run batted in
and taking off from
first base and that's gonna be a gap
shot
and so polanco scores todd frazier going
to be waived home and there is the first
two
rbis
for michael perez and a three nothing
lead for the bucks in the second
that's hit to the gap in left center
field and buxton dies and makes another
tremendous catch the ball leaving home
late you think well that's a double
and then you remember who's out there
the ball leaves the bat and you think
it's a double and then you're following
the line of flight watch this now watch
him close
no way he's going to catch it and then
all of a sudden out of nowhere he gets
there two on two out bottom two and now
cave
that's to the gap in left center field
polanco will score ostadio to third
and cave comes through with a two out
double
the four pitch walk loads him up and now
we'll see luisa rise back here with a
chance to tie the game if not for the
twins on top
toward
center
catch made by reynolds
the twins get one
michael perez
it's fun to see him double into the gap
in the second inning to score two his
first two pirate rbis
and perez with a fly ball to deep right
field and clear the deck
cannonball coming first home run for
bucco backstop
michael perez
and the pirates take a 4-1 lead on
target
that ball was touched i mean just an
absolute
missile and now to left field and kevin
newman
goodbye newman
his first back-to-back jack for the
bucks
at target field in minneapolis
it is 5-1 pittsburgh boy does that feel
good for newman i bet a weight feels
like it just came off his shoulders i
mean he got it hit taking away his last
at-bat
by the center fielder and then he hits
one just absolutely nails it actually
great great job good awareness
it's called keeping your head on a
swivel brownie to right feet on the
frazier does not run well he's gonna
test
the arm and he's gonna score
sacrifice fly for newman caves throw
late
two and two
kirloff grounded out to the second
baseman adam frazier's last time and
dwayne underwood jr
has been quite an acquisition
got him looking back-to-back case for
underwood you're gonna see this ball and
it almost freezes polanco like he
doesn't know what to do
there's jeffers a walk on a strikeout oh
what a pitch that was that was that that
change up that's the change scroogey
kind of action
definitely has a screw we'll call it the
scroogie crews on deck here's the yo
wanna swing in a high fly ball left
center field shallow playable
reynolds in newman out reynolds fighting
the sun makes the catch cable tag head
home to throw to the plate will be
late
and cave head first diving and scoring
sac fly donaldson holding at second base
a rise
and it's a 6-2 game but now two out
struck him out looking a little tough
because almost right behind a
right-handed hitter and it's straight
it's direct and has a ton of spin
oh right away
first pitch swinging and
with sunglasses on that he likes
the flip downs philip evans
jorge polanco
and popped up how about this well
little sun action
the catch is made by eric gonzalez which
means you can raise the jolly roger
and what a road trip
what a game